bienvenue pour cette deuxième journée
des demi-finales du Global cheesecom
Championship ça lui fait
celui qui salut à tous
carro arrive avec sa belle chemise
tigrée panthérée sa musique dans les
oreilles obligatoires pour jouer pour
bien jouer dans standard mais sauf lui
donne du fil à retard ah bah ça pour il
entend il en retard du fil il va plus
rester beaucoup d'eau j'ai un dynamien 1
kg de kaki pas les plus beaux pour 2
euros prendre que trois kaki gros bien
orange bah tu prends après bien orange
ça dépend est-ce que c'est du kaki pomme
enfin ça dépend du kaki mais si c'est du
kaki normal il faut préférer du bocaki
pomme on m'a dit comment le manger donc
je sais comment faire si jamais tiens
c'est les carreaux qu'elle est blanc
comment tu fais alors faut le manger en
petit cube ah bah moi j'achète
absolument jamais de kaki pas hein
ça m'intéresse absolument pas enfin les
rafaux je suis rattraper du kaki pomme
j'étais dégoûté mais
je sais pas j'ai du mal à dire parce
qu'en fait j'ai toujours connu pour moi
le kaki pomme ça n'existe pas en fait
si je ne respecte pas le kaki pomme moi
non plus mais le truc incroyable c'est
qu'on va beaucoup plus dans le commerce
quoi du kaki PAM bah c'est pour ça que
les gens n'aiment pas le kaki ouais
c'est un scandale après sauf que c'est
un vrai fruit qui existe de base je
pense au cas qui parle
disons c'est la nature peut-être une
bêtise à 5 à cause de la 4e noire
attention c'est possible on va faire
très très attention à cela ce coup
mais je regarde ne me fais pas de dire
ce que je
c'est encore une énième écossaise
c'est terrible parce que on en a parlé
je l'ai repéré quand la Coupe d'Europe
ce coup ouais j'avais bien envie de le
jouer moi-même mais sauf comme je joue
jamais c'est con il joue tout le temps
bah il joue tous quoi et il me grille la
politesse et le jour où je serai là pour
le jouer je me prendrais 25 coups de
théorie je vois rien quoi ça sera
l'horreur c'est absolument terrible n'a
qu'à pas faire 4 c'est terrible aussi il
a pas un jouet dans les pas de visite
the little gage comme on l'appelle moi
je suis complètement dégoûté dans les
écossaises quand j'ai pas le le foot
casse blanche
[Musique]
de toi-même quoi je respecte pas du tout
ce qu'il y a eu des deux alors
normalement ça va pas être la révolution
mais bon au moins
une partie du jeu d'échec après par
contre je serai très heureux de Madame
en F3 je suis très heureux de la
structure depuis enfin je suis heureux
de certains trucs quand même après oui
des petites tours je préfère ça qu'une
berlinoise
ça se trouve c'est une autre manière de
jouer c'est peut-être un peu mieux quand
même que les Blancs c'est plus agréable
même si la jauge ne juge pas
votre question je sais pas j'aurais fait
à quatre moi j'aurais fait j'aurais pas
du tout respecter à 5 j'aurais fait ça à
4 sans trop réfléchir
mazor est fait à 4 aussi non mais en
fait surtout que quand tu connais la
partie de visite il a gagné tellement
simplement comme ça
4 il est fait KF3 il a monté sa dame il
a fait tour 2 tours
attaque sur A5 et G7 il a gagné
20 coups quoi contre oriental
c'est pas non plus
non mais bon tu dis tiens je vais faire
pareil enfin est-ce qu'un chat joue
mieux que rien ne t'arrive mais après tu
auras la réponse peut-être que oui en
fait c'est un chat est plus fort qu'un
plot qui
qui a parlé de Damien penos ce matin je
fais les échecs des blisteries très très
fort enfin il suit un peu d'amis en fait
il se dit oui bon franchement c'est
beaucoup plus impressionné par mon
niveau aux échecs que par l'Australie ce
soir
l'Australie on va aller concasser faut
blisserie aux échecs c'est vraiment fort
hein
il a pas tort il suit quoi en fait j'ai
un rêve serait d'organiser un match
entre Damien penaud et Kingsley coman
quoi ce serait quand même beau en fait
on va pouvoir contacter Kingsley quoi
Damian c'est très facile mais du coup
faudrait pouvoir faire ça et qu'ils
aient un niveau pas trop éloigné aussi
bon je pense que si jamais Damien est un
peu moins fort c'est pas très grave ça
va aller mettre des caramels c'est
plutôt ouais c'est plutôt l'inverse qui
sera inquiétant
ça se trouve il est très bon aux échecs
du foot il s'est blessé puis bon bah il
a du mal à revenir bien sûr mais en fait
il était censé être très bon quoi il y a
des cons sur les déchets qui lui chie
dessus quoi
donc j'ai pas envie de me [ __ ]
complètement de sa gueule enfin un mec
qui fait tout ce qu'il peut puis bon bah
il peut pas grand chose mais il se bat
bon bah voilà avec tous les jours de
santé sont toujours dire ça en fait ça
fait des saisons que je t'en sortir ça
et qui sont nuls qui mouille le maillot
je peux trop rien dire en fait c'est
hyper inquiétant parce que ce matin du
coup tu t'es retrouvé quand même dans
les dans les valeurs des Françaises
ouais bon après je regardais sans être
enfin je regarde quoi mais elles ont
décidé un truc c'était de c'était de
gagner le match c'est vrai qu'aux échecs
on ressent moins ce truc là
malheureusement en fait ce qui fait
chier aux échecs c'est que c'était une
position de merde tu as beau voir date
façon le mal est fait quelque part ça
dépend plus trop de toi enfin ça peut
mais bon il y a pas que ok il faut que
tu te fais bouffer un pion mais on se
bat et enfin voilà tu te bats mais bon
si l'autre se bat mieux c'est fini enfin
ouais c'est un peu chiant ça tu te
traînes ton truc quoi c'est pour ça que
j'aime bien les les matchs en Bleach il
y a des parties qui s'enchaînent et tout
comment tu peux te battre
trois points tu dis ok quoi c'est enfin
je mets des barbeul quoi alors que tu as
ça dans bah dans plein d'autres sports
malheureusement
tu te fais défoncer mais tu t'accroches
tu essaies de choper un jeu de faire un
peu tourner le truc tu changes tu joues
moins tendu plus bon mais plus ça puis
bon peut-être l'autre est trop fort il
te défonce quand même mais ou pas ou
enfin peut-être mais tu as pas ça aux
échecs en fait si tu t'es fait défoncer
au début tu as quel est le moins
on va peut-être être obligé de ton
cahier de manière plus bombée après mais
bon ça a rien changé quoi enfin
cruel comme jeu
c'est pour ça que ouais des matchs c'est
pas mal parce que justement là tu peux
adapter tes ouvertures tu peux tu as
plus de ça bah ça ressemble plus à un
sport quoi mais donc faut faire plus de
parties moins longue ça ressemble plus à
ce qu'on veut faire ce que Bronstein
voulait faire ce que plein de gens
veulent faire depuis longtemps essaie de
faire le mal champion du monde sauf que
c'est tellement long que oui mais là le
problème c'est que c'est 8h la partie
donc en fait
[Rires]
[Musique]
ça serait genre 17 en 30 jours quoi
enfin oui bon tu as bien le temps de
revenir certes
qui se passe dans cette partie entre les
carreaux et Wesley bah je sais pas ce
truc là en fait enfin
si il se passe pas énorme mais il peut
ça peut quoi dire qu'il y a un
déséquilibre les pions sont plus trop
symétriques il y a de au centre de halal
les blancs un peu plus ont passé à les
noirs qui ont passé des
bons plutôt les colonnes centrales enfin
je préférais plutôt les blancs mais
après les blancs aussi mais bon si un
jour tu commences à te faire fixer tu te
rends D4 ça te ferme ton fout tu peux te
retrouver mal aussi
tu fermais le fou après C4 une fois que
tu as vu le cavalier là peut-être que B3
sera plus faible puisqu'elle drain ouais
c'est pas pas trop simple à juger en
fait c'est vraiment plus ou moins
équilibré d'ailleurs on va suivre la vie
de la jauge qui qui jauge égale
on prendrait tous les deux les blancs à
choisir
mes trois grosses tubes oui non en fait
enfin donc oui c'est un pion aéré sur
une colonne ouverte donc oui après le
truc c'est que tant que des deux tu le
défends bien et il est dur à attaquer
parce que tu as pas de pièce légère qui
vont venir l'attaquer facilement donc
après un plan des Noirs ça pourrait être
de essayer d'échanger ce cahier des deux
mais bon vous trouvez comment ou en
profiter s'il part etc donc voilà donc
c'est potentiellement une cible c'est un
pion
de la structure il est faible mais après
faut trouver comment et je il y a pas de
plan simple pour aller le taper parce
qu'en même temps toi tu as des pions
pendant au centre et ça aussi tu dois
mobiliser des pièces dessus donc
j'imagine cette dynamiquement équilibré
chacun sa faiblesse quelque part
j'ai envie de me mettre dans ce clouage
peut-être un cahic catch je sais pas un
truc un peu tactique
et j'ai l'impression qu'il veut forcer
des quatre en fait
non
réfléchi pour le faire en tout cas
peut-être il faudrait pas trop d'idées
sinon aussi il faut dire qu'il a fait un
peu à contrecœur je sais pas
c'est pions plus mais ce pion il va pas
suffire
c'est génial en fait quand il rentre
tout le temps les trucs qui qui enfin
ouais tu peux le plus fermer le quoi
c'est son seul objectif dans sa vie en
fait quand il est quand il est ouais il
est moins bien autant donc la faire
tourner comme mère la finale de cavalier
ou quoi qu'il a quand même pas perdu
mais c'était pas loin et ça sent mauvais
en fait de faire ça à chaque fois il va
finir
en position tu te fais un peu enfin tu
défends quoi donc tu remets
alors que là il y avait pas de raison en
fait il avait un truc il pouvait faire
des quatre qui est des seins et je sais
pas
nul on verra bien ce qui se passe mais
t'es pas obligé
parce que le pion est fixé il a les toit
qui attaque et bon après il veut son 3
contre 300 mm mais je pense pas qu'il
soit moins bien mais
disons qu'il y a que lui qui peut perdre
alors qu'il était dans un truc à trois
résultats et oui comme tu dis à force de
le faire au moment tu vas en perdre une
tu vas mal évaluer un truc tu vas faire
une connerie ou il y a que les Blancs
qui peuvent gagner cette partie c'est ça
voilà c'est pareil c'est que tu as un
pion moins si tu fais une erreur bah il
va y avoir un pion passé là si les
blancs ils mettent mal la pression bah
il va juste par le pion à 4 et c'est nul
c'est ça c'est beaucoup moins grave que
l'erreur est beaucoup plus grave pour
les noirs et même psychologiquement quoi
de jouer toujours avec la pression de
devoir être précis c'est c'est plus
compliqué quoi puis de temps des petits
pièges là j'imagine que dame prend un
quatre peut-être je sais pas si on a
vraiment mais
tomber 4 peut-être on va voir
[Musique]
une défense de toute façon la jauge
bouge pas et sorciers pas mais je sais
pas ce qu'on joue en fait
c'est je trouvais ça
bon là il l'a vu il l'a vu mais en fait
à un moment donné tu fais une erreur de
calcul tu perds instantanément alors que
comme tu le dis les blancs bah il y a au
pire tu as pas vu F5
non mais tu peux encore jouer même ce
truc
nulsions
j'accepte jamais nul dans un truc pareil
le truc qui est cool par contre c'est
que sur G3 il a le temps de faire tour
ah mais tu auras deux encore
ça avec les Noirs ouais mais bon
pourquoi tu joues des trucs pareil
qu'est-ce que tu t’emmerdes à rentrer
enfin tu as une position tu veux faire
D4 il y a des cinq et ta chance
réciproque alors peut-être tu vas la
perdre mais peut-être tu vas la gagner
pourquoi qu'elle a envie d'aller
s'emmerder à jouer un truc comme ça oui
tu vas t'en sortir mais ouais tu vas
t'en sortir une fois deux fois 4 fois 5
fois 6 fois 8 fois 9 fois et la deuxième
fois tu vas te prendre une peau de
banane et t'en sors pas et tu perds le
match à 0
dommage 7 mais oui elle est nulle elle
est pas très dur mais oui
mais oui on verra bon on va voir comment
il Caro essaye de poser des problèmes
j'ai assez nul théorique mais j'aurais
jamais fait le truc je pense que ça
marchait pas
j'ai peur que tu te reprennes tour qui
avait en D8 à la fin qui te bloque le
cloche sur la première mais je sais pas
enfin j'ai comme j'ai pris la position
exactement tête
pour les gens les blancs ils ont envie
de faire roi H3 H4
si leur arrive en G5 il serait bien
ouais et en fait le truc c'est déclarant
un H3 il veut lui coller un échec sur la
colonage et il peut pas passer quoi donc
c'est juste ça qui se passe donc là ça
tourne en rond à rien faire mais on va
dire c'est le danger donc la Naka tant
d'autres choses il veut passer vers des
4 5
voilà et donc les Noirs en fait ils
l'empêche chaque fois de faire ce qu'il
veut alors c'est pas de méga dur
d'empêcher je veux dire il suffit de
voir tiens qu'est-ce qu'il veut ok
chiant la répétition faut juste pas
craquer donc là il attaque voilà le pion
G3 derrière il se remet à partir de ce
côté mais non tu as cours d'idée avec
les Blancs quoi j'espère juste une
connerie des Noirs tu peux rien faire
là maintenant tu peux plus bouger la
structure depuis
pas assez grand chose
OK
[Musique]
bon bah ça c'est nul qui a dans beaucoup
de livres
[Musique]
OK
et dans l'autre partie je sais pas
curiosité donc c'est Annie qui était au
blanc
c'est un peu plus animée comme partie
apparemment
qu'hier tu avais la valeur surprise là
[Musique]
je crois qu'il y a vraiment envoyé une
prépa
ça sentait pas quand même
[Musique]
de l'argent en jeu donc tu peux sortir
une petite prépa sur un ticket excessif
que
je veux dire après bon je peux pas dire
que ce soit écrasant ce qu'il ait trouvé
enfin qui est ici c'est pas mauvais
mais effectivement on sent la valeur
surprise c'est moins
moins fort que le premier jour
bonne partie un Aniche d'ailleurs
compenser sera un peu dominé
tactiquement mais pas du tout il a super
bien joué
partout
en fait
[Musique]
escarcelles et donc le 13
il peut faire le tournoi + 10 clairement
je sais pas combien de ronde dans le
truc il y en a trois de jouer il y en a
7 6 5 ce qui est 26 51 là en prévision
en prévision je crois
bah là tu peux t'attendre
deux et pas loin je sais pas
ça a commencé un c'est de nouveau
cette fois-ci c'est la petite italienne
ça on a vu beaucoup aussi des italiens
comme celle-là c'est pas si simple voilà
c'est l'info que tu lâches
non mais en fait c'est
j'ai envie de dire que jusqu'à un
certain niveau c'est juste tu sais même
pas pourquoi tu joues c'est juste pour
être Maya enfin tu vois mais eux ils ont
tellement étudié le truc des dizaines
d'heures il y a des micro nuances les
machins et que c'est pas c'est pas
anodin quoi chaque coup tu vois elle a
le manœuvre de tourber un tour on sait
pas ce qu'ils font quoi
je commence ce qui se passe quand il
voulait faire descendre avec les Blancs
et voir l'empêche il y a même dangereux
je joue pour la colonne A mais c'est pas
hyper naturel de trouver ses coups par
toi-même c'est juste analyser comme un
beuh
l'ordi et compagnie quoi dire personne
j'aurais comme ça tout seul sur
l'échiquier en ayant encore 14-57 à ce
moment-là quoi donc voilà donc c'est des
positions comme je dis que jusqu'à
même niveau grand maître pas top top
priori ça va donner des nuls à chaque
fois parce que bon ok c'est insipide
mais eux ils ont
dit ko comme un peu tout à l'heure avec
son téléphone il est prêt à perdre de
temps pour provoquer à 5
c'est un peu chiant ce fou qui en A7 et
à chaque fois tu as des ABAB et bon bah
ok il est défendu par le cas ici mais du
coup cette l'immobilise et puis un des
tactiques des trucs donc au moins bon ça
c'est réglé guérisheim beaucoup plus
intéressant
je suis pas d'accord ici ils sont
nettement moins fort ouais peut-être la
position là il est intéressant j'en sais
rien je suis pas dessus mais celle-là
elle est pas neutre en fait ok c'est
symétrique mais tu vois c'est peut-être
un peu mieux pour les blancs pour
plusieurs raisons en fait les blancs
décident d'ouvrir la colonne à ou pas
avec apprend B donc j'ai une tension qui
choisissent c'est eux qui peuvent te
dire je peux prendre je vais rentrer 7e
ou je sais pas quoi ils ont déjà la
tour-render sur l'autre colonne ouverte
il contrôle bien le kg 3 il peut aller
vers F5 s'il veut et le qui est les deux
il peut aller vers b3c5 donc toutes les
pièces sont plutôt un peu mieux que
celle des noirs
après il va falloir frapper dans le bon
tempo quoi voilà c'est pas énorme mais
j'en sais rien si ça suffit mais je ne
sais pas juste un truc ou c'est tout
égal ou symétrique il se passe rien
enfin ces techniques mais
avantagement quand même ouais c'est un
bel avantage quand même
dur à convertir mais c'est sympa
je serai de la convertir encore moins
contre des joueurs comme ça
même je pense pas mais je saurai que
c'est moi qui j'aurais pour être mieux
tu sais que tu joues le gain quoi voilà
et le tournoi est homologué ouais malgré
le cette présence obligatoire de musique
ce qui moi m'a étonné personnellement
oui alors pourquoi simplement parce que
ça dénature quand même le jeu et la
concentration prenante tu as juste pas
le droit dans un vrai tournoi tu viens
pas avec ton ton casque et ton baladeur
ou ton MP3 enfin peu importe quoi c'est
carrément interdit
donc normalement c'est pas le droit là
c'est l'affaire une fois pourquoi pas
c'est peut-être la modernité Fab
je pense ça va refaire
nulle
je vais faire à 5 le kibé 7 il reste en
B7 si il bouge fréquent ici 5 et je vais
faire tourner trois Dame des 1 je sais
pas quelque chose ou rien au pire je
fais nul
puis peut-être quelque chose
si je vais pas à 5 par contre je sais
pas ce qu'il fait à 5 si tu fais pas à 5
j'y vais après
au moins il fait un coup pour prétendre
faire un truc c'est pas grand chose mais
voilà ce serait beau les lacs du
Connemara quoi comme musique si vous
pouvez choisir moi ça me saoule rien moi
ça me rendrait fou
une petite nulle qui se profile Fab
uleux encore ces quatre peut-être le
bruit blanc
parce que je crois que c'est ça a été
discuté tu es vraiment obligé de voir la
musique ah bah voilà une petite boule ça
fait plaisir
il pouvait faire un truc là que c'est
que ça c'est vraiment la barre
le même scénario que la partie d'avant
en fait la manche d'hier quoi
c'est à dire que Guy la première il
perdue la seconde bon bah là si on en
croit la barre blanche à gauche de
l'échiquier ouais donc là ouais mais il
est pas trop bien parce que il est un
peu les pièces ni n'importe comment avec
les mains en plus il y a une tour
attaquée c'est un peu la merde quoi je
sais pas comment il s'est retrouvé là
c'était quoi le début
je comprends pas ce qui fait en fait
trop de créativité sur la créativité
c'est n'importe quoi en fait c'est pour
ça vous dites belle partie mais en fait
c'est de la merde ouais enfin je
comprends c'est belle partie parce qu'il
y a une victoire mais la partie en soi
tu pourrais même bouger ta dame en fait
tu t'en fous tu le laisses là au milieu
de français
je sais pas quoi
[Musique]
un coup de grâce
champion
8 et tu auras étant G8
qui va arriver malgré tout
ce match belle victoire je passais le
mot mais victoire écrasante de Daniel
dans cette partie qui égalise 3 3 dans
les deux matchs trois partout ouais
l'égalité parfaite on va sûrement aller
vers un armage
ok les quatre le mieux c'est fou c'est 5
mais faut se rappeler un peu après ce
que je doute
[Musique]
et là
des signes que je crois ou 7 et des
signes
ou après tu as fait un fougère
donne tout mais ils font perpète en fait
mais il faut se rappeler
on va voir si il se rappelle en fait si
tu veux la montrer c'est fou prends des
seins que tu y prends
des trois grands rock
là
il y a C3
[Musique]
il prend
h&ms ça c'est facile
mais paire de fou en face pas mal
d'activités un peu serré mais je pense
il est dans son élément n'accueil il a
beaucoup d'avance à la pendule donc
c'est un travail qui passera rien je
pense ce sera Sarine Naka la finale et
si c'est ça va être un
ton pour un carnage
c'est que du coup son point fort entre
guillemets il est
pas assez fort pour
le sur le reste il est il est bien
derrière donc
H3 ok mais attention quand même parce
que ça peut
voilà
donc
il fait pas de gueule en fait mais c'est
bizarre parce qu'en fait les courses
plutôt d'un macadre fois
[Musique]
peut-être pour un peu toucher et puis il
faut FC
quoi enfin je fais pas attention
assiste te faire chier je comprends pas
du tout
mais je comprends pas ça tu peux
retourner je vais jouer assise
si c'est un autre coup ça peut rendre
plus mais bon moi c'est moins con quoi
ici c'est vraiment bizarre cette ça peut
être un mystique réellement
[Musique]
après comme je dis là c'est pas tout à
fait comme quand tu es chez toi et que
le mec est chez lui
en face tu veux peut-être pas donner
d'infos quoi
j'aurais peut-être fait mais c'est pas
du tout parce qu'en fait tu as même des
parents je me dis tu sais quand tu as un
danaka Damas 5 il fait B3 et le cavalier
ça sent le missclic ou une faute très
bizarre
non moi je pense
du coup on se laisse subi un peu
attention
dès le début
c'est bizarre mais bon c'est très con
quand même je reviens à 6h de missclique
que en fait on regarde un match pendant
8 heures pendant 2 jours et que ça joue
sur ABC sur le dossier ou je sais pas
quoi c'est pas sûr on sait pas en soi
bon après je sais pas ce jeu je sais pas
s'il va la gagner mais en tout cas il se
fout dans la merde saut mais tu sais pas
si c'est un mystique
moi ce serait le seul truc que je
demanderai en fait non mais en tout cas
il résiste mais ce B6 c'est peut-être
pas un mystique en attendant je n'en
sais rien le coup est bizarre mais en
tout cas il a peur après comme dit tu
pourrais très bien avoir un mode ou tu
dis confirmer le coup ça ça existe ça a
existait d'ailleurs
et à toi et libre à toi de le mettre si
tu veux éviter le missclic et ne pas le
mettre tu peux le désactiver quand tu
veux ouais quant à moins de 2 minutes ou
quoi tu viens j'en ai marre de confirmer
ça pourrait être faim c'est pas que ça
pourrait se faire c'est que ça se fait
déjà sur d'autres plateformes réussites
assez con pour disclique après de
confiance
je pense qu'entreau je tenterai si
j'étais Naka pas moi parce que contre
moi j'aurais le lien après mais si je
bah oui c'est normal en fait
il va se [ __ ] dans la merde il va
finir par en perdre une ben peut-être
mais c'est beau c'était tellement un
coup de merde en fait ça peut même
permis un sale fils de qualité enfin
l'optique de saut de faire nul mais tu
sais qu'il est capable de la perdre
d'accord
en fait je comprends que c'est chaud
quoi tu as dit qu'elle allait qui
peuvent débarquer tu as l'air un peu
fébrile la tour bon bah la pâte colonne
pour s'exprimer à fond je sais pas mais
bon
je sais pas ce que ça vaut enfin bon tu
vois la petite turbinette elle aime bien
les Noirs quoi donc c'est vraiment pas
le service de qualité de l'année mais ça
se tente en pratique après ce qui est
beau c'est que tu as tellement
l'impression que soit il va te reprendre
une répète dès qu'il peut que du coup tu
t'énerves tu t'énerves à un moment donné
tu risques ah maintenant finalement je
ne répète plus je ne viens pas
là ça va là je peux la faire gaffe s'il
a fait B3 l'équivalent du B6 et c'est la
même merde parce que ça donne les cases
noires et tu vas peut-être te faire
retourner
alors dis donne gagnant après la F3 mais
en plus d'un F3 d'un machin je pense
qu'il va le faire c'est tellement genre
[Rires]
que le coup le plus pleutre est le
meilleur tu te fais changer les dames à
coup sûr en fait voilà tout de suite la
gueule et dégoûté là et le problème
c'est qu'il va neiger tout enfin là il
va
y arriver
parce qu'en fait d'autres aurait
peut-être hésité quand même avec dames
prends F2 pour prendre un punto mais en
fait
[Musique]
trois c'est pas mal là tu peux vraiment
pas perdre avec les noirs
c'est dur de prendre une fourchette avec
le fou qui tient la cassée
en fait
une faute de saut quand même face ça me
dégoûte pour Naka qui perd de la dessus
franchement
non c'est magnifique
c'est très drôle quoi ouais non mais
c'est drôle en fait c'est juste qu'il te
bat il te fait chier à faire que nul et
tu dis oui pourquoi pas faire nul alors
tant pis tu fais nul tu vas essayer la
partie d'après tu finis là tu dois dire
oui mais je peux quand même faire ça je
tente un peu de toute façon il va faire
nul si jamais il va il va se jeter sur
la moindre nulle et en fait
à la cam il est complètement dégoûté ah
c'est terrible c'est quand même c'est
quand même de l'argent qui s'envole
peut-être
plus de 100000 bah il est très heureux
là et très très heureux il est tout
sourire
tu pensais pas que j'allais faire ces
choses là
[Musique]
il se voit ils sont en face l'un de
l'autre côté
en plus tu as pas un échec tu as rien
quoi
allez super énervée je crois qu'il a
raté
c'est un grand mot mais
c'est 6 pourquoi pas
très important en fait
quand tu vois le fil de départ c'est
quand même très favori ah bah super
favori et c'est le temps sur internet il
y a le plus d'argent de l'histoire je
crois enfin il y a absolument personne
enfin tu as pas tu as pas les raisins tu
as pas réglé
personne quoi ils sont tous fait
éliminer sur Internet enfin tu es
vraiment très heureux presque à mon
érable
je pense il peut rater
je pense qu'il permet à pas cavalier F3
il y a fougé 4 non je pense ça aussi il
y a un piège qui est prend fou prend
tu vas arriver
c'est pas possible bon c'est
bon
c'est quand même la merde
non
ça doit perdre ça quand même oui
en plus le pion il arrive
[Musique]
c'est terrible il était à deux doigts de
la sauver
il y a niche qui a fait nul il est
écoeur
[Rires]
[Musique]
tout le long du
trucs on lui a fait une remontrance
terrible
il joue pour revenir mais saut du coup
peut-être pas le meilleur choix quoi de
laisser cette année je me sentais mieux
que 4 en fait
c'est une Estelle
il se renseigne
ouais mais H3 il va faire E5 lui-même
avec les noirs
de Dubaï au tennis de t'assurer énorme
pour un si petit tournant du coup
palmarès à 8 x 20h 5 fois de Djokovic
bah ouais mais c'est ça en fait et c'est
sûr que ça te fait chier genre c'est
quand même s'il fait des rêves en fait
il y a que des plots dans le tournoi et
on demi-finale hyper contre Marine Cilic
bah là c'est pareil sur la physionomie
du match si tu es Naka sur toutes les
sportifs surestiment toujours parce que
c'est juste bien de le faire et ils sont
comme ça ils ont raison d'être comme ça
c'est sûr qu'ici ok un tel comme sauf je
perds tout seul enfin il doit se dire je
pouvais pas perdre une partie sans trop
abuser en fait non mais ça me fait
vraiment
ouais
quand même pas le parti après pour
essayer de revenir il a fait perdre la
partie d'après c'est marrant d'ailleurs
et il arrivait à faire nul sur le match
mais il aurait perdu la onzième en
faisant ça trop de marche quoi il a pas
voulu rentrer dans surprendre si on
prend qui est G4 6 il fait ça
G4 ça fait mal quand même [ __ ] il y
avait de le faire c'est logique en fait
je sais pas comment dire il est pleutre
mais contrairement faut jouer les coups
parce que de toute façon tu vois que
c'est bien il va faire et puis en plus
si tu fais pas en fait c'est encore pire
le cavalier va rebondir enfin tu fais H3
tu l'envoies en H6 tu lui fais G4 c'est
hyper logique tu as le fou qui va partir
en G2 tu as [ __ ] trois dames des deux
grands rock
évidemment de base tu veux pas un rock
opposé mais celui-là il est quand même
magnifique pas de recoposé comme ça tu
en joues tous les jours même dans un
dans une partie tu dois faire nul enfin
tu joues et puis si tu es mieux tu es
mieux en fait
il va le faire mais c'est trop logique
en fait c'est
[Musique]
peut-être pas le coup de la merde
pour essayer de forcer un peu les choses
a priori faire fouille et puis là tu
fais KFC
il est obligé mais c'est joli quand même
là ce qu'il vient de faire avec le
cheval
carrousel quoi en plus tu peux revenir à
F6 tu peux bien redessiner
faudrait qu'il puisse revenir dans ce
sens-là
c'est très beau
c'est bon en fait tu fasses ça de
manière infinie c'est assez beau quand
même Fab mais peut-être que ça fait
aussi un truc infini et te réclame la
troisième position quoi je préfère quoi
d'infini de jolis tu fais un même chose
la même chose de l'autre côté était très
heureux et tout le monde est heureux et
tout on dit oui très belle partie
magnifique je n'avais jamais vu ça
peut-être ils pourront nous faire des
toiles à partir du mouvement de pièces
ou tu as des flèches de toutes les
pièces qui a enfin se représentées dans
un carré ou même mais ils ont fait ça on
efface les cases mais ça a été fait
champion de souris font ça ils font ils
le vendent même en NFT après hein
d'accord magnifique
après tu peux l'acheter
en NFC après c'est le NFC des parties tu
allais t'as les couilles qui se dessine
ça te fait un dessin et c'est ton dessin
en NFT
tu as été devancé par cette idée de
génie
merde
mais bon là faut pas trop regarder la
jauge j'en sais pas si
parce que c'est pas une partie
jaugeesque mais je crois qu'il Carole et
il en Full Tilt mais je vous dis en fait
que ça le fait chier les gens me croient
pas c'est terrible dans le chat toi il
s'en fout machin et tout faut pas il est
très énervé non machin tu dis de la
merde bon bah tu regardes la partie il
se trouve que j'ai raison mais c'est que
ça fait combien de fois en fait qu'on a
raison et que tout le monde nous chie
dessus Fab ouais non oui enfin non mais
il est énervé en fait le oui c'est con
la foule 4 il y avait un truc qui tue
qui est passé
et surtout B7
c'était fini tout de suite c'était pas
très dur non restez hyper facilement on
peut montrer hein c'était vraiment très
simple mais bon faut jouer vraiment le
gain quoi c'est ça le problème donc j'ai
5 qui va se dame F3 et double attaque B7
c'était le coup qui gêne évidemment et
là E60
tu prends pas ça peut la merde quand
même
[Musique]
ou puis on prend roi fit pion France tu
prends du roi
qui a réussi c'était terminé ouais la
partie
bon qui a fait un truc logique ça va
être toujours très bien
mais bon de laisser la bête blessée en
vie attention
surtout que si d'un cas la vue je sais
pas moi j'ai toujours un truc quand je
vois quelqu'un atteint un gain assez
évident je vais y aller faut s'accrocher
ouais malheureusement
non
enfin l'ordinateur il propose quand même
cavalier C6 tourner un qui est V8 enfin
bon
ça c'est NFC
magnifique truc c'est lui tout seul qui
l'a créé quoi
le coup de peinture
est-ce que tu penses que soit il cherche
à faire nul là bah oui non en fait non
mais si l'envoyer il saute dessus
même dans mes
d'avoir un intro du B4
pour un joueur du niveau de saut
maintenant c'est que je sais pas trop
dans quel état il y en a qu'un
il a hyper énervé
c'est en fait qui joue pas enfin qui il
a envie d'y aller mais que dans un état
qui n'a pas le
mais ça c'est incroyable même là tu sens
ça plus tritude extrême
quand même il voulait pas au début ça
casse des cinq ratait bien blindé mais
maintenant que tu bouffes le caille au 7
là il va échanger faire foudre
je dois dire ça y est c'est un peu la
merde je suis un peu dégoûté mais
peut-être Jarnac
[Musique]
regarde il est très heureux B5 AB il va
te faire fouter 5 il a l'air très
heureux là je pense qu'il va faire
foudre puis on prend on reprend qui est
assez simple il doit dire cela
devrait déjà penser évacuer le sien quoi
il échange juste tout en fait ça ici il
va tout prendre j'avais vu en fait
honnêtement c'est si j'étais sur Kiss
c'est exactement la même idée mais je
m'étais dit ça tu peux te faire arnaquer
quand même mais remarque non roi C2 qui
est des trois tu prends
le malaise
[ __ ] il joue vraiment la nu à fond
hein
c'est vraiment un malade mais tu sais
qu'il est capable de la perdre
non mais attends il va perdre ça mais en
fait
un jour
et je sais pas bon après normalement les
pièces bougent quoi
c'est Imposs comment tu veux jouer aux
échecs en fait
il va réellement perdre ça
il le sait en plus il va la gagner
regarde
c'est hallucinant ce qu'il a fait ouais
c'est incroyable d'avoir autant peur en
fait
voilà elle est quand même dure à perdre
c'est la crise parce que la finale fou
contre cavaliers elle est peut-être dur
à défendre parce qu'en fait j'ai peur
pour lui que tout reprendre à F3
cavalier E6 vous prend aussi tu reprends
à 4 soit vraiment trop facile
tu auras jamais d'attaque de match sur
le roi avec les noirs et ça je pense
c'est trop facile de faire nul par
contre j'ai réussi à garder toutes les
pièces ah ça y est il est heureux il a
vu fou prend le 5 salut il a été heureux
il a fait un petit coup de tête
vous ferez 5 foi F4 3D 2
prend on reprend
non mais c'est incroyable ce qu'il fait
ouais c'est pourquoi tu fais ça en fait
mais tu imagines à quel point ça doit
être dur pour lui de jouer aux échecs
Wesley parce que ça s'explique que par
la peur en fait oui et du coup c'est pas
confortable pour lui de jouer il doit
pas se sentir bien en fait pour jouer
comme ça ben non ok peut-être qu'il
fasse 3 C2 tour des cartes 5 tu reprends
C4 3 B
[Musique]
il me fait de la peine sur en vrai c'est
triste enfin c'est triste
pas
c'est comme ça enfin
dire si il a trop du mal à jouer bah oui
c'est triste en fait mais c'est pas
jouer
un truc tous les jours de ta vie que tu
aimes fondamentalement pas quoi
peut-être qu'il aime bien les échecs
mais que la tension compétition ne peut
pas
parce que là c'est que psychologique en
fait c'est pas parce qu'il a ce qu'il a
joué c'est impossible
jamais hyper ça enfin ça dépend si tu
mets cette position de base tu dis
peut-être ça mais si tu vas d'où ça
vient ah non mais il peut perdre enfin
genre cavalier 4
trop de pièces qui t'attaque quoi c'est
chiant tu as aucune prise sur les cases
noires c'est pas tes pièces il y a des
fourchettes il y a le il y a la pendule
mais elle aurait peut-être dû jouer la
finale faucon de cavalier
[Rires]
ah [ __ ] le pauvre comment tu peux
perdre ça non mais j'espère qu'il va
gagner ça quand même c'est trop c'est
trop de perdre ça on est dans
l'irrationnels
il était tellement gagnant c'était
simple c'était hyper facile que bon bah
du coup il veut switch de défense en
fait il veut essayer de sacrifier la
dame maintenant contre les deux pièces
[Musique]
c'est que les approches de cavaliers
pour aller vers B4 TD4 c'est cavaliers
aussi tu le bouffes c'est cavalier assis
tu le bouffes donc il a mis un set up il
se fait pas toucher facilement faire nul
son point fort ultime mais c'est pour ça
que le match contre guéri ça peut
promettre
guérisse à peu promettre
non mais en fait je comprends qu'il est
tout le temps faire nul c'est un tel
soulagement que la partie soit fini
enfin je joue plus et j'ai pas perdu
les pièces qui étaient chiantes là on va
pas de menaces noires immédiatement en
tout cas ah mais ça va être très
longtemps ah bah oui faut jouer assez
vite pour ce garder du temps on va voir
si ça
c'est chez qui F4 mais après peut-être
qu'il s'est dit que si le laisse tourner
pendant des plombes
moi aussi mais en fait peut-être c'est
pas si con comme décision parce que
c'est vrai que ce pion F c'était ce pion
G5 c'était plus une prise dans la
position des Noirs
par là-bas à un moment donné je sais pas
tu prends un tour de échec il fait roi
D1 et peut-être que tu as un peu moins
en danger à l'elroit aussi
il était un peu enlevé de la case F4 non
mais en fait je sais pas il est l'heure
mieux saut de savoir que maintenant il
doit plus que faire nul et défendre il
suit moi enfin il suit mais il suit
quand même le cavalier qui va revenir en
D6 il va quand même se prendre une
couille ah c'est sûr c'est trop dur à
défendre
je pense qu'il veut se changer le set up
et se mettre le fond en détroit des
clous de toute façon
mais je pense qu'il vaut vraiment
repartir avec le roi vers eux il en a
marre quoi
ok
[Musique]
ça fait du bien hein
mais il va faire après damaka
il repart de l'autre côté il est écœuré
oh il boit le calice jusqu'à la lit Naka
là ah mesdames ici s'il est encore
tourné 6 un roi ici ça va encore
reculé là d'accord
tu t'enlèves les faiblesses petit à
petit là
c'était malin autour des 6 [ __ ] un peu
la merde faire perdre du temps
[Musique]
chaud
il va faire H5 là j'ai 5 et sur H4 tu
prends
pourquoi
il est en train de choque
j'ai peur qu'il fasse dame j'ai deux
tours des deux bah maintenant il faut
ranger 5 c'est en train de tourner
encore Fab et ben voilà une partie sympa
avec un peu de pression
il est sous pression là Wesley Hikaru
qui fait le taf
il a plus que 17 secondes le joueur
américain ces deux Américains la veille
en un des deux qui a plus de 18 secondes
et ce qui suit ou est-ce qu'il suit pas
parce que d'un autre côté il a quand
même liquidé une aile
et il y a peut-être moins de réseau de
maths mais j'en sais rien Fab non
on a cassé
dame j'ai 83 E7 c'est pas si simple
encore attention Wesley c'est chaud
et n'a qu'à concentré comme Jaja il y a
quand même 200000 balles aller chercher
peut-être fait un échec dans ta F3 tu se
sent grand comme une maison la gaffe est
où il perd au dernier moment et il se
fait défoncer dans leur magasin c'est
quand même gros comme une maison a
priori c'est le scénario mais bon
il va essayer de jouer les pronostics
on a qu'à servi en place oh c'est
terrible
quelle idée d'être allé donner spion âge
quand même
voilà c'est dur là
il va pas trouver le coup trois secondes
une il va pas y arriver
fabuleux
il va se faire raffaler bien joué fou
aussi tellement un coup d'enflure mais
très bien joué parce que ça empêche les
échecs
il repère encore le pur à 4 ah c'est
terrible il s'est fait bouffer un pain
mais
il fait quand même un gros taf pour pour
pas se prendre de fourchette
de logique toujours se mettre en
diagonale face à un cavalier quand on a
peu de temps
qu'est-ce que c'est dur
il peut bouffer le piano et c'est ça il
a dû regarder
qu'est-ce que c'est dur favrois de pas
de fourchette encore peut-être
il a raté une tour en un
mais ça qu'il a un perpète il y a
peut-être un perpète Fab
ne perd pas
mais en fait il joue aucun coup pour
gagner Wesley
cherche même pas je pense parce que
c'est pas dur hein il le menace là quand
même et fousser 6
et c'est gagné pour Wesley
il est dégoûté
ah c'est terrible il est écœuré éliminez
éliminer Fab ah ok bon c'est cool pour
Wesley qui finit quand même par emporter
cette partie
malgré lui mais c'est beau c'est saisir
c'est bien et prends le dame C4 échec
quand il a vu de va être content ouais
oh là là mais c'était c'est incroyable
qu'il est défendu quand même qu'elle
défense ça semblait vraiment impossible
[Musique]
c'est un des seuls joueurs au monde qui
pouvait défendre cette position vu le
scénario de la partie je pense
[Musique]
j'ai même pas sûr abisa par lui et car
Yakine je vois pas qui d'autre pourrait
défendre ça en fait au monde va jamais
Carlson dans un tel scénario il en peut
généralement
de la grande époque quoi on repart les
amis avec Annie gigari on a deux caméras
sur Giri là
c'est reparti en avance cette fois-ci
on s'y est comment pouvait pas
s'attendre en avance quand même bah non
parce que ça repart toujours en retard
qui a pris les noirs et qui a dû prendre
13 minutes exactement magnifique je me
dis que franchement moi je veux bien
même 10 minutes
donc ça peut être
peut être trompeur donc le coup d'envoi
de rugby est parti ouais mais la femme
on est on est sur l'armaguette donc
quand même mais il est peut-être pas mal
là non genre tu prends tu fais fou F6 tu
tapes partout
on va à l'impact
du premier rock premier mot le porter
quoi important les premiers vols portés
Fab pour mettre de l'impact physique
c'est qu'à l'époque à l'époque du du
rugby à l'ancienne tu avais des joueurs
ils partaient en fait leur plaisir au
coup d'envoi c'est les piliers ou quoi
c'était que tu remettes des ballons pas
trop loin pour courir à fond et genre le
pilier il arrivait bam dès le premier
coup quoi tu l'impact quoi touche pas à
ça
en tout cas ce dont on parlait c'est la
partie food et 7 il veut faire fout à 4
qui a essayé 4
ça arrive de partout peut-être à quoi
trop avec les Blancs peut-être mais
peut-être fou B5
et tu viens lui taper le pion parce que
tu t'attaqueras
qu'il est en train de se faire guérir
on verra bien guérira le dernier et ce
sera probablement à Nice on nage dans le
bonheur avec Fab notre chouchou notre
poulain on va avoir notre finale de rêve
la fiche
ça va être une affiche de folie
cavalière à
37 Damas 8 allez on va aller taper
là-dessus peut-être même tout racisme
peut-être allez il faut y aller il faut
y aller allez à niche va nous chercher
cette finale ah nous on serait super
nous on serait des supporters
d'anishafont on aurait les banderolles
ce serait beau d'aller avec les le tifo
Guiri quoi on ferait un chalala ah les
guiris
[Musique]
à fond quoi et on aurait pu dire et
bravo les carreaux pour les 80 000
balles
en plus il a un fond vert derrière
un drapeau breton
ça c'est le beau jeu ça c'est la niche
qu'on aime
mais attends
cavalier F3 faut prendre fous prends ces
trois
genre la dame pas trop de cases
trois fou prends et tout reprend C3
peut-être pas pour Aniche alors on ça
donne quoi le temps Fab 8 28 contre
bah ouais c'est pour ça que j'ai
attention quand même non mais trois
c'est vraiment
vraiment difficile
aurait pu trouver
ne sous-estime pas Fab la puissance de
guérir
allez il se place
pas notre douche
[Musique]
une bêtise mais eux trois fois
c'est terminé
il y est pas encore
le jour indien
un peu dans la merde quand même ce que
[ __ ] il va se prendre C8 ok l'ordi
fous des quatre parce que sur Full prend
des quatre si on prend des quatre tu as
pas trop vite ok bon c'est très gentil
hein
tu peux mais en fait il va pas faire
bon sport
en fait le truc
ça dépend si tu as déjà vu le thème
en B2 à la fin en fait le plan roi F1
roi machin roi B1 tours bouge roi B2 il
te fait hyper mal tu vois même dans le
scénario tu changes tout tu restes avec
le pion des 4 tu as le pion à deux il te
reste une tour chacun la tour en B2 et
tu vas ramenera jusqu'en B1 quand même
non
je suis fou furieux
si tu as le temps de faire le contre jeu
mais bon
il va falloir évite quand même une fois
que j'ai le droit en B1 après ça avance
tout seul
H5 H4 mais bon
au 3 je ferai presque j'ai 5 ans à 100 %
j'ai 6 je considère et même pas
tout de suite je pense
du couloir qui doivent te gêner dans
1000 variante ouais j'ai 5 c'était sûr
normal je sais bien jouer mais c'est ce
qu'on pense et bonne soirée
je pense c'est le bon thème pour toi
bébé
il veut peut-être doubler sur A et tout
à 3 et où mettre tout foncé 4
il veut profiter de H5 pour flash 5 je
vais te dire peut-être des fois je sens
qu'il
doit faire [ __ ] G6 c'est un autre des
défauts tu auras fait tomber deux parce
que tu pourras la même en faisant fous
ces deux
cinq Fougères
quoi que bon il fera à 4 tu ferais tout
à 5 je suis un peu inquiet moi aussi
pourtant il trouve les coups mais
[Musique]
ça consomme du temps
je pense pas
mais bon ce que tu veux faire maintenant
on est dedans on est dedans hein Fab
exactement je suis d'accord
je sais pas
en tout cas tu as plus de chance que
quatre contrats etc quoi
peut-être qu'il joue un peu vite là NiAl
ouais en fait je me pose une question au
tout début vous pouvez pas essayer de
faire H4 pour péter la structure et je
pense
hyper technique hyper compliqué ou tu
dois choisir un set up
faire flag c'est une chose mais en fait
jouer le flag à ce moment là déjà pour
Sarine c'est un peu trop quand même
et pour en revenir sur des histoires de
Flag si ça arrive là je pour faire
flaguer c'est normal
c'est pas le fourgon de fou
avantage autant tu dois jouer pour et il
a une position il entend de plus et puis
là je vais longtemps il y a là il y a
rien à dire mais ça il va pas la gagner
par contre c'est plus en plus simple
mais bon c'est trop de comment ça a joué
la montre
mais en fait c'est enfin oui c'est
beaucoup trop tôt pour démarrer ce jeu
là
F4 c'est pas si c'est clair
il peut être bien
toute cette phase de la partie bizarre
mais ça je crois que c'est encore nul ça
ressemble à la finale un peu de ma média
Rohff fearujar c'est pas tout à fait la
même c'est toujours les mêmes idées mais
tu peux les perdre mais tu peux les
perdre en fait ce serait le pion E4 et
ce serait ce serait nulle très
facilement et que le pion G4
après tu peux tu peux te faire Contrex
s'il aura rentre en G5 ou quoi une tente
de cliquer en fait juste mais bon 3 3 39
c'est beaucoup
mais là on est exactement dans la
situation de la partie dont on parlait
sauf que c'est sur la sixième rangée et
c'est encore plus facile je crois qu'on
avait analysé on avait compris ça
bah plutôt
moins de 15 après sur la colonne et
genre
de trouver une idée pour les moments
et que ça on avait compris que l'option
aussi c'était mieux
là tu refais ça le truc en fait
ah
parce que
il s'est pris le truc qu'il fallait pas
se prendre
et sur F5 il changera à prendre coupé
quoi c'est ça il s'est pris le truc
qu'il fallait pas se prendre
bon s'être rendu Sénat quoi ça va être
assez facile maintenant c'est quand même
terrible de se prendre ça elle était pas
si dur que ça des fois mais avec peu de
temps
car il pourra niche
il s'est fait cliquer
on passe à côté de la finale de
nous aussi
on passe à côté de la finale de rêve Fab
donc ce sera la semaine sauce
au rugby mais bon on aura une finale
demain
pas de rêve pas de rêve
on va passer à côté des neufs
c'est dommage on se retrouve demain 17h
pour la suite et le début de la finale
merci à tous